what we see here are two maps of
congressional districts on the Left we
see some congressional districts in and
around Austin Texas this black line
shows us Travis County where Austin
Texas is and on this right map we see
the congressional districts in and
around Chicago Illinois what I'd like
you to do is pause this video and see if
you see anything interesting about the
shapes of these congressional districts
well some things might immediately jump
out at you here in Chicago Illinois this
4th district in particular seems kind of
fishy it's often known as the earmuff
district it has this northern part and
this southern part and then it's
actually connected just by an interstate
not by the things on either side of that
interstate so that doesn't seem like a
natural shape for congressional district
and then here in Austin Texas you see
that the votes in Travis County are
split amongst many congressional
districts and so the question that
should be surfacing in your brain is why
are these districts shaped that way and
the answer that many people will give
you is it's because of the
gerrymandering Jerry man during which is
the idea of shaping districts to benefit
one political party or another every 10
years there's a US Census and based on
that census different states will might
get a few more representatives or a few
less representatives and so state
legislatures will often have to re
district and so that's when this occurs
and so the first question you might ask
is well that's a very strange word where
does it come from and that goes all the
way back to 1812 when the then governor
of Massachusetts Elbridge Gary Gary was
how you pronounced his name although now
it's Jerry Mandarin he decided to sign
the bill that would reapportioned the
state Senate districts and you have this
one really strangely shaped district
right over here that people said hey
that looks like a salamander and so they
created a portmanteau which is really
just a combination of words around
Elbridge Gerry and the back half of
salamander so you have Jerry
Mandor which is creating these districts
to advantage one party the other el
Gary did it for the Democratic
Republican Party against the Federalist
but now it's Republicans versus
Democrats so now let's go back to the
two districts that we looked at and
think about what are the implications of
it who will
who does the gerrymandering benefit so
in the case of Austin Texas Austin Texas
is an urban area urban areas tend to
lean more left and it does lean more
democratic it's actually more liberal
than most urban areas in Texas but it's
surrounded by more rural areas that lean
right and so it would be advantageous
and it is advantageous for Republicans
to split those Democratic votes amongst
these Republican districts in the case
of Chicago it's a little bit less
obvious this type of gerrymandering was
done by a Democratic legislature but
it's a little bit less obvious what's
going on here with the fourth District
because it is actually surrounded by
districts represented by Democrats what
you need to appreciate is when this
gerrymandering is done it's often done
by sophisticated computer algorithms and
there's all sorts of implications of
stretching one district or another this
is just one tactic that you see here is
taking a bunch of Democratic votes and
diluting them amongst a bunch of
Republican districts you might see it
the other way you could have situations
where you re district so that an
incumbent no longer lives in their
district and so they wouldn't be the
incumbent anymore you might see
redistricting to force two incumbents to
go against each other you might see
redistricting where you're collecting
pockets from certain constituencies so
that you can make a district so that
they would have representation and
that's the one that's often cited for
the district for right over here because
these are heavily Hispanic areas around
or in Chicago now I'll leave you with a
newspaper article from the Salem Gazette
in 1813 that talks about at least how
the Federalists felt about that first
official gerrymandering this is in
response to Elbridge Gary's signing of
the bill to allow for that salamander
shaped district that advantaged the
Democratic Republicans against the
Federalists Federalists followers of
Washington
again behold and shudder at the
exhibition of this terrific dragon
brought forth to swallow and devour your
liberties and equal rights you can see
in the picture it actually does look
like a dragon they put wings on it
unholy party spirit and inordinate love
of power gave it birth your patriotism
and hatred of tyranny must buy one
vigorous struggle strangle it in its
infancy the iniquitous law which cut up
and severed this Commonwealth into
districts is kindred to the arbitrary
deeds of Napoleon when he partitioned
the territories of innocent nations to
suit his sovereign will you got to
remember this is right around the time
of Napoleon conquering much of Europe
this law inflicted a grievous wound on
the Constitution it in fact subverts and
changes our form of government which
ceases to be Republican as long as an
aristocratic House of Lords under the
form of a Senate terrorizes over the
people and silences and stifles the
voice of the majority and then it goes
on to say will you then permit a party
to disfranchise the people to convert
the Senate chamber into a fortress in
which ambitious office seekers may
entrench themselves and set at defiance
the frowns of the people know this
usurping faction must be dislodged from
its stronghold